okay get this
celebrities
might not be the best source of
information to determine what hipaa does
and does not do
i know let's talk about vaccine
verification that's when someone asked
you to prove that you've been vaccinated
although you might expect current
members of congress to know the law
here's marjory taylor-green getting it
completely wrong well your your first
question is a violation of my hipaa
rights you see with hipaa rights we
don't have to reveal our medical records
and that also involves our vaccine
records and unfortunately now we have
thousands of other marjory taylor greens
out there all making similar claims
here's a guy explaining that it's a
hipaa violation to film a covid testing
site you're not about a film
it's a hipaa violation
again
it's always been that way here's a karen
who says she's protected from wearing a
mask by the ada and hipaa no i am i am
protected by ada and hipaa here's
someone saying the government can't ask
you about your vaccine status because
that is illegal on its face this person
dot plus dot thinks that hippa might
have something to do with the
hippocratic oath and angela barno has
some hashtag not legal advice for those
of you discussing whether celebrities
are vaccinated quote you are literally
breaking the law when you post about
some celebrity being vast or not and the
idea that someone might have to prove
that they received a vaccine has led to
some pretty extreme reactions quote
proposals like these smack of 1940s nazi
germany we must make every effort to
keep america from becoming a show your
papers society and that was from
freshman representative madison
cawthorne meanwhile libertarian justice
dimash called health papers dystopian i
guess neither of these gentlemen have
ever played a sport in school because
health papers are required or enrolled
their children in school where health
papers are required and apparently even
pointing out someone's bad hypothetics
gets you called a nazi like this from
scott travis quote okay grammar nazi no
one is allowed to ask for your personal
health information unless they are hippa
certified that doesn't even make sense
but these reactions do raise some
interesting legal issues does the
government have the power to verify
whether someone has been vaccinated can
employers ask about someone's vaccine
status and what does hipaa have to do
with any of this
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a medical malpractice lawyer there's a
lot of dodgy information about vaccine
verification hipaa and the government's
power over individuals so today i'm
going to tackle all of your questions
about covid19 and the vaccines starting
with everyone's favorite new law hipaa
so what exactly is hipaa hipaa otherwise
known as the health insurance
portability and accountability act of
1996 according to the internet is
fighting for your freedom she will stop
employers from requiring vaccinations
and will vanquish any attempt to discuss
whether a person is vaccinated
unfortunately the reality is far far
more mundane to ensure both proper
access to and confidentiality of medical
records congress enacted hipaa in 1996.
hipaa is a federal law that establishes
the rules for managing medical
information throughout the united states
although states may adopt stricter
confidentiality rules hipaa sets the
minimum standards and protections for
medical privacy hipaa also gives
individuals control over their own
protected health information or phi
including their right to access their
phi and obtain copies request amendments
to correct or complete their records
request confidential communications
obtain an accounting of who used or
received their phi impose restrictions
on disclosure of their phi opt out of
fundraising communications and revoke
previous authorizations as well as file
complaints about the misuse of their own
phi and in 2009 hippa was amended by the
health information technology for
economic and clinical health act or the
high tech act these amendments which
became effective in 2013 add strict new
penalties including the possibility of
personal criminal liability and make
compliance with hippa's privacy and
security standards even more important
and i have some bad news for all of you
freedom fighters out there hipaa signed
into law by mogufo bill clinton is not
actually a general privacy law
protecting anyone from getting your
health information hipaa is a health
privacy law that applies in very limited
situations and let's get one thing
straight before we go any further in
this video attention everyone it's hipaa
h-i-p-a-a
not
h-i-p-p-a all you have to do is look at
the words that go into the act and it's
definitely pronounced hipaa not
pronounced hepa okay
sorry had to get that off my chest now
back to what hipaa actually is and does
hipaa includes a privacy rule that
limits doctors hospitals and health
insurance companies from disclosing your
personal health information now medical
information by itself is not protected
phi unless it can be related to a person
that is it contains one or more
individual identifiers hippa
specifically applies to quote covered
entities which includes healthcare
providers like i just mentioned
clearinghouses that process medical
information and health plans and covered
entities can't disclose your phi to
other people generally without your
permission so for example two employees
were fired from the university of new
mexico hospital when they took cell
phone pictures of patients receiving
treatment and then posted those photos
to social media and a bunch of people
got fired in la hospitals when they kept
accessing celebrities phi because you
know they're celebrities though there
are definitely some exceptions here for
example if you're in a car accident
paramedics who take you to the hospital
aren't barred from discussing your
health situation with doctors and if the
police need your health information
there are exceptions allowing them to
get it without your consent however
hippa's privacy rule doesn't apply to
your employer if they aren't a covered
entity and it doesn't apply when you
voluntarily provide information
therefore hipaa's privacy requirements
don't apply to most private businesses
so for example when cowboys quarterback
dak prescott says um i don't necessarily
uh think that's
exactly important clarence i think
that's hippa he's almost certainly wrong
the hippa privacy rule probably doesn't
apply to your employer the privacy rule
doesn't protect your employment records
even if the information in those records
is health-related and the nfl is
actually a good example of how much
power employees have in this context
think about it the leak has rules about
the way that teams report player
injuries teams have to list players as
questionable doubtful or out because of
injury or illness and that's not a hipaa
violation it's an employer work rule and
the same goes for everything related to
aaron rodgers but i mean what can you
expect for someone that went to cal go
bruins so in most cases the hipaa
privacy rule doesn't apply to the
actions of an employer but i can hear
you asking the question can the
government ever make health papers
mandatory and isn't it wrong for the
government to force people to divulge
that information well look i can't tell
you whether things are right or wrong
i'm just a lawyer
but i'm a lawyer i can tell you whether
they're legal or not and if you've spent
any time on the internet you've probably
also heard the claim don't ask me about
my vaccine status or i'll sue under
hipaa well many people think that
sharing personal information with
government agencies employers and other
third parties is an invasion of privacy
and
look i mean that's a moral question not
a legal one but america doesn't have one
omnibus invasion of privacy law if
you've ever played high school sports or
taken a drug test before starting a new
job you've experienced this kind of
invasion of privacy which requires you
to disclose your personal information in
order to participate in something that
you want to do and here's an incomplete
list of activities that you can only
participate in by giving up your private
information a driver's license a hunting
license concealed carry permit school
vaccinations sports physicals
international travel immigration and
voting of course those with law degrees
from twitter.com will say that those
records are provided totally voluntarily
a vaccine verification is not but in the
eyes of the law they're exactly the same
thing you don't have to provide your
kids vaccination records if you don't
want to but if the school requires them
that means your kids don't get to be
enrolled in that school likewise you
might prefer not to provide personal
information demonstrating that you
should get a concealed carry permit but
you don't have to provide it you might
not want your employer to know whether
you've done drugs or not but sometimes
that's a condition of employment and
really there are a lot of instances when
employers can and probably should be
asking about things that might be
considered health information a person
might volunteer that information when
they call in sick or mention it to a
co-worker or the person might write the
information down on a worker's
compensation form after an injury or
fill out a health insurance form to
receive benefits and there are plenty of
state laws requiring you to provide
medical records to receive workers
compensation and if you choose not to
provide this information to your
employer the employer can generally
discipline or fire you remember in the
us most employment is at will and with
respect to covet 19 vaccines president
biden has requested osha begin
promulgating rules about vaccines in the
workplace and it may be the case that
employers are actually creating an
unsafe work environment by allowing the
unvaccinated to go to work but what
about other laws well generally private
businesses can have any rules they want
so long as they don't discriminate now
of course businesses still can't
discriminate against protected classes
businesses still have to follow title
vii the americans with disabilities act
and other laws barring discrimination
it's illegal to refuse to serve someone
based on their race religion sex or
national origin however someone's
vaccine status doesn't fall into any of
those protected categories being
unvaccinated or vaccinated is not
considered a disability the ada does
regulate medical examinations in the
workplace though under the ada an
employer can't ask a job applicant
whether they have a disability or about
the nature of an obvious disability the
employer also can't force someone to
pass a medical examination before being
offered the job however after the person
is offered the job an employer can
condition the job offer on passing a
medical examination but there are some
caveats here the employer can't impose a
medical exam on just one person for it
to be legal all employees in the job
have to take the medical exam and it has
to be related to the requirements of the
job but there are some new state laws
that are attempting to change the status
quo on medical information in florida
for example businesses are not allowed
to make their own decisions when it
comes to covid governor desantis signed
an order stating that airlines and
cruise ships could not demand proof of
vaccination anywhere in the travel
friendly state so the question is can an
employer discriminate against a person
for not taking the vaccine and the
answer is probably yes but it depends on
the context the eeoc issued interim
guidelines saying that employers may
encourage or possibly require covet 19
vaccinations but they still must comply
with the americans with disabilities act
title vii of the civil rights act of
1964 and other workplace laws so yes
subject to certain exceptions an
employer can make a coveted vaccine
mandatory but they can't physically
restrain you and jab you in the arm but
they can offer you a carrot like a 100
bonus or a stick in other words getting
fired if you refuse and if your employer
wants these specific results they could
ask you to voluntarily turn them over or
make you sign a hippie waiver so they
can get the results from a third party
because remember hipaa does actually
apply to healthcare providers and their
disclosures to third parties and on the
flip side it's probably legal for
employers to ban vaccinated people as
well though that might be subject to the
osha requirements we talked about
earlier where if an employer is creating
an unsafe work environment well they run
into liability on that end as well but
private school in florida banned
teachers who had been vaccinated from
any in-person contact with students
citing debunked conspiracy theories
about vaccine side effects the school's
assessment about vaccine safety is
completely contradicted by science and
data but the school probably has a right
to make its own rules since it's not
public and in keeping with the reality
of hipaa that it isn't a general privacy
law this school's requirement for staff
to fill out a form disclosing their
vaccine status probably passes muster so
as you can see there's freedom of choice
going in both directions but of course
what about the supreme court and
government action lots of people seem to
think that the supreme court should
immediately strike down any law that
resembles a vaccine passport but a
vaccine passport is just an immunization
record and immunization records are
legal and the supreme court has already
weighed in on it so in terms of whether
the government can make vaccines
mandatory just like employers the answer
is probably yes but there are also many
many caveats the landmark case on this
is called jacobson massachusetts which
we've talked about many times on this
channel but a short summary during a
smallpox outbreak in cambridge
massachusetts in 1902 the state
introduced an ordinance requiring all
adults to be vaccinated or re-vaccinated
against smallpox the penalty for
non-compliance was a 5 fine and a man
named jacobson refused the vaccine
saying it violated his religious liberty
now states generally have the right to
regulate the health safety welfare and
morals of its citizen these are known as
police powers however these powers have
been balanced with individual liberty
interest and the question was whether
the u.s constitution prevented the state
from implementing vaccines the supreme
court held that the constitution did not
prevent such a law from going into
effect but effectively the public
interest in making sure everyone was
vaccinated overrode the personal
liberties in this particular case now
jacobson was decided in 1905 this is a
case involving a state law but it's
likely that the same result would be
reached with respect to the federal
government as well so long as the
federal government has the power in
question remember the federal government
is theoretically limited more than a
state government is if the federal
government has that power then it's
likely that the constitution isn't going
to prevent such a law from going into
effect and then some people are pointing
to the nuremberg code as something that
would prevent a vaccine mandate or a
vaccine passport
the nuremberg code which is not a u.s
law
no that's probably not going to prevent
the government from implementing any of
those laws but on a slightly more
reasonable note there's the question of
whether hipaa overrules the vaccine
mandate and there is an argument that
hipaa prevents vaccine mandates and
vaccine passports it's wrong but there
is an argument the argument goes that it
would be illegal to mandate a vaccine
because doing so requires the government
to find out who has been vaccinated
under this view of the law vaccine cards
would also be illegal because of hipaa
because the vaccine card is a health
record but that's a pretty incorrect
interpretation of hipaa as we discussed
the law prohibits the release of
protected health information by covered
entities without your consent who are
these covered entities again well health
care providers health insurers and
medical billing companies what do they
have to do well they have to keep your
information confidential safeguard
against security threats and make sure
employees know how to protect your
information so unless you work for a
health provider or insurance company and
you are a patient and client of that
company at the same time your employer
probably isn't constrained by hipaa and
neither is the government and even
healthcare providers have the right to
ask their staff about their vaccine
status since they are requesting the
information they're not releasing it to
a third party so the bottom line is that
hipaa means health providers can't
release your information about you
without your permission the law says
nothing about whether you can or should
answer questions about your vaccination
status or other health issues hipaa
doesn't apply when you are talking about
your own health and of course hip has
all kinds of exceptions carved out in
the law itself so even if hipaa applied
the only thing you'd need to do to
create another exception is pass the law
the same law that probably requires the
vaccination or vaccination status itself
but whether you're staying home to avoid
the anti-vaxxers or living life to the
fullest because you got vaccinated you
need comfortable clothes and as the
weather is changing i stocked up on
sweaters from mac welding like this one
this tech cashmere v-neck sweater is
insanely soft and warm it has the
stitching here on the shoulder it's slim
fit and even though it's wool and
cashmere it's not scratchy because it
has a cotton interior it's genius it
goes great with my radius joggers and
obviously my mac weldon boxer briefs and
if i'm not in court or on a zoom call
with a judge i'm often wearing mac
weldon they focus on smart design and
premium fabrics i order in multiple
sizes and have them shipped to my home
then i just returned the ones that
didn't fit me right and keep the ones
that fit perfectly and with mac welton's
loyalty program you can get 20 off free
shipping and access to new products it's
automatic when you sign up in order at
macweldon.com legal eagle now if you'd
like to try mac weldon and you'd like to
get 20 off your first order just click
on the link that's on screen right now
and use the promo code legaleagle at
checkout so just click on the link
that's on screen or the one that's in
the description to get 20 off your first
order plus clicking on that link really
helps out this channel and while you're
at it click on this playlist over here
with all my other real law reviews so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court